all right let's get into um audience
questions for the week
very important relevant questions that
tie together
a lot of the different issues that we've
been discussing first one is hey david
if the third quarter numbers really are
as good as donald trump predicts
uh could that rocket trump to
re-election
on november 3rd so understand the timing
uh
first quarter is january february march
the first quarter numbers came out on
april 30th
as an estimate and then they were more
fine-tuned on may 30th
the second quarter april may june we got
estimated
second quarter numbers on july 30th and
then we will get
presumably more accurate and precise
numbers on august
30th so that means that for the third
quarter
uh july august september we will get
estimates of gdp on october
30th that is four days before the
presidential election
so uh i would not just
be thinking it's possible i would be
thinking
it's almost a guarantee that on
october 30th there will be good
gdp numbers why why will they be good
well
when the gdp goes down more than 30
percent
you have a new significantly lower
baseline
a record low baseline meaning any
increase
is going to seem relatively larger now
bear in mind
think about the number 100 if you start
at 100 and you lose 30 percent you're
down at 70.
if you then gain 20 you go back up to
84.
okay down thirty percent up twenty
percent you start at a hundred
you go down to seventy you go back up to
eighty four
you will hear trump claim on october
thirtieth
this is the biggest rise in gdp in
american history
and it will be true on a percentage
basis because of that new
lower base of 70 so to speak
but we will still be at 84. we will
still be
imagining it's 20 percent up we will
still be down
16 from where we were before the second
quarter so
will the economy really be doing great
when we get that announcement no will
donald trump
try to take credit for it of course
and will donald trump claim that it is
the best gdp
result we have ever had yes now i am
worried about this
i i genuinely am worried about it why
because there's a lot of
really um
ignorant people there's a lot of easily
manipulable or manipulatable i don't
know if either or both are words
uh people and there are also people who
really don't want to vote for joe biden
and they will look for any excuse not to
do it and so
inevitably we need to plan for it on
october 30th we will have
96 hours before the election during
which we will need to fight
the talking point that no one has ever
overseen a bigger gdp increase in a
single quarter than donald trump
and it will be true uh but of course it
will not be reflective
of the broader economic situation and
that
is uh really what we what we all need to
remember and listen this gets me back to
poll says biden's up nine margin of
error
is 3.5 that means it's possible biden's
really only winning
by two if trump swings just
one percent of the population on october
30th by
saying look at this great gdp victory uh
that might mean biden wins the popular
vote by one
and you can as we know from 2016 you can
win the popular vote
and still lose the electoral college
we've seen that with hillary clinton we
saw it with
al gore in the year 2000 we've actually
seen it several times
so we need to be very very vigilant
there's going to be we need to plan for
it okay
and in fact this is where democrats are
just terrible
we know this is going to happen on
october 30th
trump will claim that he has fixed
everything
and brought us the biggest economy you
all know you know economic prosperity
all that stuff
what do we do for those 96 hours to
ensure
to ensure that it doesn't work to swing
the election in his favor i don't know
what the answer is but it's
going to happen and we damn bel damn
well better have a plan